DreamWorks all-singing all-dancing
trolls are back in a holiday special
which finds poppy branch and friends on
a mission to create a new day of
celebration for the Bergin's UPK movie
lovers it's Jan here and today I'm going
to reveal some cool details and Easter
eggs you may have missed in the trolls
holiday special and I'm running a trolls
book giveaway on this video to enter
make sure you're a subscriber and leave
a comment below about the trolls movie
or special when the cata bus falls into
a wormhole is a lovely easter egg to the
original troll toys that these animated
characters are based on biggy branch and
poppy all turn into little plastic
trolls like the troll toys that was so
popular in the 1960s and again in the
1980s and 90s and guy Dimond turns into
a little plastic troll covered in
glitter which is funny because the
character of guy Dimond who's naked
except for glitter was created as a
tribute to the original troll dolls
which often didn't wear any clothes as
for Cooper he turns into a giraffe troll
toy just like the original set of animal
trolls that were the inspiration for the
design of his character in the movie
later in the special is another shout
out to the original troll toys when
poppy and branch sing a song suggesting
a whole range of holidays the Bergin's
might like to celebrate among those
holidays is good luck troll Day which
involves putting a gem in your
bellybutton this is a little tribute to
Thomas damm the Danish creator of the
original troll dolls who named his toys
good luck trolls and it's also a hat tip
to the 1990s toys called treasure trolls
which had a little jewel in their tummy
button which you could make a wish on
when the cata bus crash lands in front
of king Gristle's castle the next thing
we see is loads of butterflies
fluttering away and those butterflies
are the same colors as the caterpillar
that took poppy and her friends to
Bergen town which is a nice touch
because in real live caterpillars do
transform into butterflies and in case
you missed that another caterpillar
explodes into butterflies during the
troll abrasion by the way something
similar happened in the first trolls
movie when the DJ stage bug burst into a
mass of butterflies while poppy was
giving out invitations to the trolls
party there's lots of cool little
details on the cata bus Express for
example if you look at cloud guy you'll
notice he's whoa
blugh driver cap which has a cloud on it
that's the same shape as he is and the
controls on the buses dashboard are
similar to the bug defibrillators that
Brandt used to bring poppy back to life
after she was attacked by spiders in the
first movie the holiday special also has
a few little reminders from the trolls
movie of King Gristle's first date with
Bridget
aka Lady glitter sparkles first of all
there's a pepperoni pizza lying around
the throne room and like their first
date which they spent at captain star
funcles roller rink they also end up
skating in trolls holiday though this
time as it's winter they go ice-skating
rather than rollerskating
unlike the troll tree in the movie if
you look closely at the troll tree in
the holiday special you can see that
it's shaped like a classic trolls hair
just like in Poppy's holiday
presentation two bridges and gristle and
speaking of her the top of Bridget's
thrown in the Bergen Castle has a
similar shape to the her star she had as
lady glitter sparkles to sell their
various holiday ideas to bridges and
gristle poppy and branch dress up in
crazy costumes and perform a song and
dance routine this sequence is a hat tip
to branches voice actor Justin
Timberlake and his many Saturday Night
Live skits playing a guy who sells
everything from vegan food to wrapping
paper while singing and dancing and
crazy outfits there was actually also a
nod to Timberlake's SNL sketches in the
trolls feature film when poppy did a
song and dance dressed up in a basket
costume wearing white gloves
the only time Biggie's pepper mister
dinkle speaks in the feature film is
when they discover Creek is alive and
instead of reacting with his usual
squeaky-voiced Mew sound he says oh snap
in a deep voice in that movie mr.
tinkles was voiced by the film's
director Walt Dohrn who also voiced his
cloud guy but because mr. dinkles has a
bigger role in the holiday special
he's now voiced by prolific voice actor
Kevin Michael Richardson by the way in
the final scene the words happy holidays
to all and to all a good night
or a spin on the last line of the
popular poem a visit from st. Nicholas
which is also known by its famous first
line twas the night before Christmas now
what did you enjoy most about the trolls
holiday and were there any other cool
details you spotted let me know in the
comments below and don't forget to also
subscribe for your chance to win an
some trolls book and announce the winner
on an upcoming video so if you enjoyed
this make sure you turn on your
notifications and hit that like button
and while you're here why not tap the
screen now to watch more of my trolls
and other animation videos thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers